there's not much to save for some
residents in this neighborhood of the
belgian city of liege
most furniture and appliances are ruined
cars wrecked the flood waters that have
caused so much damage have finally
subsided
but the cleanup has only just begun
the water covered the cupboards pascal
is still shaken
rising waters had forced her and her
teenage daughter
to climb onto their roof where they were
stranded overnight until a neighbor
helped rescue them she says it's only
once they were safe
that reality struck me
we have nothing left no home no
furniture or clothes
it's so hard but i say to myself at
least i saved my child
as a mother that's the most important
it'll be some time before residents in
neighborhoods like this one come to
terms
with what has happened but what is
lifting spirits
is the fact that so many people have
come here and rallied around to help
handing out food and water or lending a
hand
on nearly every affected street
volunteers
it's about solidarity supporting people
to show they aren't alone with this
devastation
when they see all these young people
coming to help them during their summer
holidays
well it's just amazing and heartwarming
belgium's prime minister visited the
town of rochefort
he's called the floods unprecedented but
this scientist says
climate change is to blame
the rainfall was of course exceptional
but all of our climate data shows that
it could happen again in the future
emergency workers continue to move
people from areas and homes considered
unsafe
as they reach regions that were cut off
by flood waters
they say they may find more bodies as
dozens of people are missing
the hope here though is that they'll
find survivors
natasha butler al jazeera liege belgium